It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts at FUWAMOCO Morning!
We are.
Yes, indeed.
Thank you Ruffians for joining us for our 153rd episode!
Thank you FUWAMOCO Morning!
Does it not feel like we're just at our 135th episode?
We talked about how time goes.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Bow to the BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Hi!
What does that even mean?
I don't know.
Ruffians are being silly, huh?
Well, for Ruffians that are joining us, maybe for the first time, maybe you're just a little bit sleepy and forgot what is language.
What are words?
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday,
Monday aka FUWAMOCO and it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
And to do so, sometimes it can be good to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
You know, it's a new week.
It's gonna be a good new week, you know, Ruffians.
Sometimes we feel like it.
Some days, yeah.
Some days, no.
That's okay.
I love you too, Abyss.
BAU BAU!
Wow, a new week.
There's a bunch of things.
A bunch of exciting things maybe coming up.
Except for some things.
I mean, don't say something right away, I get nervous.
Pero the...also...not a Pero, right?
It's a clinical list too, but... Huh?
But?
It's not.
BAU BAU!
Who's Pero?
Well... If we show where Pero was sighted, maybe they'll...figure it out, but... Let's check it out!
Where was Pero sighted this time?
De-den!
Happy kodomo no hi!
To this day!
BAU BAU!
It's pretty bright color.
One thing doesn't quite match though, huh?
That's the... You know Pero's drunk up there, you know, along with all of the lively fish kai.
You know.
Kodomo no hi.
It's Children's Day.
Five.
Five kodomo no hi Children's Day.
But on kodomo no hi, you put up a koi nobori just like this.
A fish plate.
I know.
To be able to kind of wish that my children get strong and healthy and successful.
Like, oh, the koi.
Yeah.
Right.
Pero is a koi fish now.
That's why they're up there.
I don't know.
He did that himself.
I don't think so.
I don't know.
His tongue sure is flopping in the window, huh?
Yeah.
You know, I don't think that Pero will quite bring strength and happiness and health and success.
I don't know either, but... A nasty koi flag!
I feel like you catch a lot of air.
Probably a lot of bugs.
Probably, but... I don't know.
I like to think you know.
There's a Ruffian that had a little Ruffian.
And they wanted to celebrate Korou no Hi this way.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh, you think Pero could break a string because he's all muscle?
Well, just because you have muscle doesn't mean that you're strong.
Really, Moco-chan?
It's the truth.
True strength comes from multiple places, you know?
Like the heart?
Yeah.
Well, I'm glad Pero's up there and not us.
Pussy though, I don't know.
The Koi!
They're the best up there.
Yeah.
Then they can swim!
BAU BAU!
Happy Children's Day!
Golden Week.
In case you didn't know, Children's Day is a part of Golden Week.
Which is a string of holidays in Japan that line up for a week.
But not this year.
It's kind of funny.
But, but, but, but!
Ruffians, we have some happy news!
Our very first song cover, Ayo Asobi's Kaibutsu, has now over 7 million views on YouTube!
7 million!
That's wow!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you!
Congratulations!
Bakaibutsu, you know all our cover songs, all our songs really mean a lot to us.
Bakaibutsu especially so.
Not just because it was released right after we debuted, but also because of the meaning, the lyrics behind the song.
Ruffians, did you know?
Actually, when Kaibutsu originally premiered, it had English lyrics on the bottom translated by us.
Did you know?
But for certain reasons, you know, they had to be removed forever.
That's okay though.
It happens!
You saw, you remember them, but they're not there anymore.
In fact, we didn't even know they were there at one point.
So I'm happy that they were there at a moment.
But more than anything, we're just really happy that we're able to sing this very special song and share our performance of it with you.
That's all.
I'm sure you didn't know about it.
I'm sure there's, you know, Ruffians watching right now which have not listened to Kaibutsu.
And you know what that means?
It's a good chance to go listen to Kaibutsu!
But you know, FUWAMOCO, we really want to continue to sing lots and lots and lots for you.
So it'd make us happy if you could maybe listen to our music here.
Singing is important to us.
You know, and that way we can share our feelings with you that way too, so.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
But, uh, speaking of singing... Oh?
Well... A certain demon of sound... Yeah!
Nerissa Weaver!
Nerissa!
She released a brand new cover song!
Together with...
Elizabeth!
FUWAMOCO!
We're in our first duet together.
Of a song that we very much love.
It's an anime song from the anime Revolutionary Girl Utena.
And we knew about it before.
I love singing this song.
It's my go-to karaoke song too.
So when Nerissa said, FUWAMOCO, I'm gonna be covering this with Elizabeth, I'm like... Oh yes!
Finally!
Yes!
Good!
If you haven't heard of Utena before, you could say it's a magical girl.
It's definitely a magical girl anime, but maybe not a magical girl anime.
You're thinking out.
It combines... What kind of genre is it?
I don't even know.
What would you call that genre?
Rock, opera, drama.
Love.
Magical girl.
It's amazing.
It transcends genre, yes!
I don't know, but I think there's another song that I like better.
Yeah.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
FUWAMOCO!
Beautiful.
Magnificent.
Now I'm starting to think, if we were magical girls together with Nerissa... Yeah?
What would we be?
I sort of feel like Advent would be like... Doremi.
Not Madoka?
Madoka.
That's an easy answer though.
Who loses their head?
Shiori.
Oh my goodness, I thought it was me for sure.
I don't know, Shiori is horrible.
It's Fuwawa.
Can I make it Nerissa at least?
Huh?
Nerissa's a candidate for that, no?
She loses her head every other day anyway.
Okay, it's Nerissa.
It's Nerissa.
Yes!
Okay, I get the... You convinced me it's Nerissa.
Yes.
Okay, but we're gonna avoid spoilers even though it's been how many... It's been over a decade.
So, yes.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Please check out more inside Elizabeth's cover!
Let me show Nerissa who's this red.
BAU BAU!
Well, as we mentioned right now, it's Golden Week, a stream of holidays in Japan.
So there's a bunch of cool events going on for a little bit of a limited time.
A little bit.
There's a bunch of fun events going on for a limited time.
And one of them that's very exciting to us is there is a
hololive figure exhibition going on right now in Akihabara!
Together with Good Smell Company and Ami Ami.
They're putting it on.
But if you go over to the famous Akihabara Radio Kaikan building.
You know the one in Spine's Cave.
If you go there, up to the 10th floor, you can go see a bunch of hololive figures.
Only hololive figures!
The ones from Kotobukiya, Design Coco, Max Fudgey, Furyu, Kleenex, Bandai, Animus, etc.
etc.
So many figure theaters that we love too!
Ina-senpai has been doing a big, big job recently, so you can see her there too, but you can also
FUWAMOCOdechu.
Yeah!
I found the printer on display there!
Also on Android, and I believe as well the app is designed for FUWAMOCO.
Yeah!
So you can go and check them out.
If maybe you didn't get a very good look at Expo, or you weren't able to head to Expo, you can go check them out there.
Admission?
No admission!
It's free!
It's free for when you'd like to.
Except today's the last day, so...
You have until the 6th.
The end of today.
But that means you still have a good chunk of hours to go.
Many hours.
But here you can also get cute little acrylic stands on Android Designs.
And free stickers!
Free stickers too!
But!
The stickers are great!
They're very cute and all!
They're shiny!
Yeah, they have a little bit of a cute shine to them.
I was surprised because so many Ruffians were taking photos and I was like, they're so cute!
Right!
And they couldn't tell it was two!
We just gotta send this one more FUWAMOCO, right?
I want more, please!
We just can't go and get our own paws on them, right?
Past the figure exhibition.
Excuse me, give me my stickers please!
Thank you!
If you happen to be in Akihabara, maybe you could swing by the Radio Kaikan.
You know, FUWAMOCO, we love going to these events, you know?
There's so many different events and exhibitions going on in Akihabara.
Yeah, and especially if you know, you have a bit of time, you don't really have any plans, just going to some of these free events, just looking at things is so inspiring.
It's so fun, you know?
Oh, this illustrator's doing an exhibition.
I've never heard of them, but that looks cute.
Oh, I'll go check it out.
Oh, okay.
Oh, maybe I'll get an acrylic face.
BAU BAU!
I'm just so happy.
That was so much fun.
And lots of fun.
We recently had a bunch of fun.
A little bit of spooky fun.
Because FUWAMOCO, we had a mini horror game matsuri recently.
Somehow we ended up playing horror games.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
To be honest, I'm surprised that I have not seen any clips from it yet.
Hi.
I think there's a lot of Ruffians.
Maybe.
It should be maybe change from broken boy to mind broken.
Yeah.
It was a masterpiece.
If you have not seen it, it's not that long.
Yeah.
We went in, you know, excited.
Gonna go on a Japan trip to the next country side.
Oh, what's wrong?
That was beautiful.
Everything was wrong.
The game, it was beautiful.
But that was very interesting!
You never know what's gonna happen once a year!
Recommend.
We recommended it to all of our... Don't tell them.
Don't tell them.
Yes.
Yeah.
So, if you haven't seen it, watch it.
And after that, we're trying to move on.
Wrap ourselves around reality again.
You know, we decided to play another game called Debug Deadline.
Which is fun!
It was really fun.
We became really good debuggers at the game company, Doki Doki Games.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It was a really fun game.
Aren't you a personal favorite?
Lots of silly things.
There was para para.
Para dan.
A lot of different references to things.
Was it even scary?
At the very beginning.
It was scary at the beginning.
The first time you see the bug, yeah.
And then you see it again and again and again and again.
Okay, dodge the skeleton.
It like breaks.
I'm scared here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Dodge.
I said five games, we played six games, no?
And then we played Witch's Creek, but it was really intense and scary, so that didn't last for long.
And then we went on to our final game, Tsugu no Hii!
The new one!
We learned about the terrifying horror behind phantom characters.
Kanji.
So then we had a bit of a kanji lesson together with the Ruffians!
Yeah!
And that was my horror game!
Let's do it again!
It was a bunch of fun!
So, maybe if you're feeling, oh maybe let's just have a little bit of a small spooky break, you can join us for one of those.
Broken lore?
No recommend.
I was almost crying.
We were crying.
I was stomping my feet.
You had a nightmare from Tsugunohi.
I was so tired I just fell asleep actually.
I didn't even make it to Moco-chan's bed.
I didn't even get an eye mask on.
I don't even think I plugged in my phone.
You did it Moco-chan!
I just zonked this goo.
No time for nightmares.
No time, just sleep.
But it was a lot of fun, so we hope that we can have more special events like that together with you in the future, Ruffians.
In Tsugunohi's defense, the next night when I woke up in the middle of the night, I was scared.
Yeah, it didn't stop.
BAU BAU!
And Ruffians deshita, you've probably heard something's going on right now.
But!
hololive English!
We've just started a brand new part of our
Minecraft Roleplaying Event Enigmatic Wrinkle in 2!
Yes, it's the new chapter of Tales of Fate!
Although if you weren't able to join us for Chapter 1 back in September last year, don't worry!
You can join us right from the beginning here.
Right, Moco-chan?
What?
Ruffians, do you want a summary of what happened?
Do you want to hear the summary from Fuwawa?
Off the top of her head?
A summary of N-Reco 1 and the lore of N-Reco 2?
Disclaimer!
It may not be entirely accurate.
ENigmatic Recollection Chapter 2 Chains of Fate.
We are now in the ancient Labesto.
Labesto is
The place that we were last time.
Yes!
But, uh, well there was the Lobesto King, and we were trying to do stuff, get memories back, and then we found out he wasn't so much nice like a king, he was more bad, being controlled by the stains.
And the enemies!
And then he became a king stain!
And we took him down!
Corruption!
But then, that wasn't actually Lobesto, it was just a, a big Lobesto!
And then, he became the outsider.
And then, so now, we are now in a different place.
And, but, we found a cute rat?
Cat?
Cute.
A cute, called Fia!
And Fia's lost some of her memories.
She's part of the library.
She's a library.
Cute.
And, now, we're trying to help.
But the library is invisible.
The library's, oh, is that important?
Moco-chan, really?
I think so.
But!
Now also in Ancient Labesto, we're trying to help Fia find her cute memories.
And there's a king-queen-queen-princess, Ephania.
She's pretty nice.
But there's a prophecy.
And that we only have seven days until the Ancient Labesto is over.
And we're trying to find the outsider.
I said that, right?
But there's also the outsider.
Yes!
Who is the same king who was the Abyssal King.
Yes.
And now we've also heard about this outsider.
This outsider's... No, no, no.
Outlander.
There's an outlander and... No.
Outlander!
You're right!
There's an outsider bad.
Outlander good.
That's where we're at.
And the outlander is...
A swordsman, mysterious swordsman.
Good.
And we are the shining stars.
Shining stars, that's me.
And we're gonna save things.
Yes.
Does it sound correct?
That is an record in a nutshell.
A full nutshell.
And it is roleplay.
Yes.
You know, like I mentioned, it's Minecraft roleplay.
That sounds correct.
Yes.
Yeah.
Nailed it!
Yeah!
But you know, to be able to start all this celebration off, there was a very silly 3D program that introduced a new chapter.
And introduced balloons.
Balloons.
There was Calli-senpai, Korone-senpai, Biboo and Nerissa.
We played some games while sharing info and record.
And there was a big scary balloon pop.
Oh no, I just got an idea.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
More balloons!
Are you thinking about putting... Oh.
What if... I hide the balloons.
Oh, and then... Go to the time and... Pick up the balloons.
Oh!
I was thinking about, you know how, I remember having our second anniversary coming up.
Why don't we have like a balloon popping race where we break into teams and we have to pop them?
You have to sit on the balloons!
No, no, no!
No sitting on the balloons!
You have to use teamwork, Moco-chan!
You have to pop them together!
I was thinking a race where we pop the balloons with our bottoms.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Would you like to see that, Ruffians?
You better see how scared that both Biboo and Calli-senpai got about this massive balloon.
But.
Yes, yes, you would like to see that.
You would like to see Biboo and I run into each other and pop a balloon with our bodies.
Wow, Ruffians.
That sounds fun.
But not just fun and record fun going on.
There's also a brand new theme song for this new chapter called Monster.
It's such a cool song.
So jazzy.
And this time we have Ina-senpai, Connie-senpai, Shiori and Gigi singing it.
I can't remember if I remember it right now.
I'm gonna hum something and then tell me if I'm right.
Okay, I wasn't certain.
I thought maybe it was some other song.
No, it's just really jazzy, really good.
It kind of has a bit of the Cowboy Bebop feel to it actually, right?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
It gets me so hyped up.
Why?
But we hope that you'll join all of us as we continue our journey in MRECORD!
Who knows what will happen!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
I think it's time for the Doggie of the Day.
The Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is...
It's Jackson!
FUWAMOCO!
That's a wild little punk!
He's so cute!
But, uh, does he look like a grandpa of the house to you, Moco-chan?
No, he looks like a baby.
Right, right!
Baby grandpa!
That's his name, Baby Grandpa!
Baby Grandpa Jackson!
But look!
The curls!
The color is so cute!
I want to poke that nose.
No, no, I want to pull out the tongue.
Pull out the tongue?
I want to pinch it.
I was going to say I want to poke it.
I want to poke it and pull it.
Poke and pull it.
That's very cute.
Moco-chan, how does Jackson BAU BAU?
Well, definitely not like a grandpa, I don't think.
Maybe more like... BAU BAU.
BAU BAU.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Today I went on a walk.
What is this?
The strongest walk to a gym!
Good on you!
Getting up to the gym!
I'm really happy that we can help you with your gym journey!
Do your best!
But make sure you stretch a lot, you know?
It's a giant donut.
I don't think you want to try biting that one.
I don't think it's very soft.
Then we'll go from the gym to the dentist, maybe.
Lots of appointments.
Make sure you stretch.
No biting this!
No!
Only do the injuries.
But form is important.
And sleep too!
I say you know, right?
We're not your coach.
We're demon dogs.
BAU BAU!
Good luck!
See you guys!
BAU BAU!
And for the Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
When you travel, do you usually listen to music or catch up on sleep?
Were there any hololive songs you listened to during your trip?
I kinda slept a little bit, but really more than anything.
Okay, this is the time that I can listen to music!
Mococo.
Yes.
New demo, huh?
You know, we're learning for any kind of reason.
Yeah, you know.
Breaking dimensions.
Yeah, breaking dimensions.
Odyssey was one of those.
Yeah, but you know.
So, yeah, we listen to a bunch of hololive songs and also hololive songs that have reached our ears too.
Yeah.
Yeah, hardcore unreleased long demos.
Why?
Did you hear Mon-chan beforehand?
No!
Because we're not a part of it.
Yeah, but we... We heard it the same time.
Almost the same time.
We heard it start again though.
Huh?
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah, so... I'm always very happy when demos get shared.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
Thank you for all your submissions.
Please remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something we make together.
You know, you're a part of this.
That's all.
You know, please use the hashtag.
Send it!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Give us your questions, Ruffians.
Send it!
You know, there's no better way to ask us a question than through this hashtag.
We have a question, you know, and post it in chat, but then we don't read it.
One.
Pero Sighting's not so happy, but it's important.
The Ruffians need to know.
I love seeing your walks too.
So don't forget to use the hashtag okay?
BAU BAU!
And we have another stream coming up later this evening.
Very soon we have De-den!
I schedule.
Tonight, we're gonna be having a members-only stream with the Doggy Pack!
This time, we're gonna be doing an after-party for our most recent cover song release of Crescent Moon!
Yeah!
Our very first English cover song!
Yeah, Crescent Moon!
If you haven't listened, please go listen!
If you just go to the videos page, then it's right there.
Right there!
You know!
But this way, usually we'd have it, you know, a little bit closer to where the videos were.
Yeah, usually next to the really...
Doggy Pack.
I'm looking forward to it.
And then, also you know, this week more N-RECORD!
FUWAMOCO Morning N-RECORD!
And the N-RECORD finale will be on Saturday the 10th.
The big, dramatic, I'm sure, conclusion.
Something happens, huh?
Something does happen, it's the conclusion.
And then, on the 11th, we're gonna be having a very special hololive among us collab because it's BAU's birthday!
FUWAMOCO's first birthday!
A big birthday, so we couldn't be there playing Among Us.
I know how that went last time.
It went, it went, yeah.
Swimming.
Yes.
So we hope that you'll join us by this week, especially in our
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Now for the Ruffians joining us in the archive!
New FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU Koi Koi!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Pathfinder!
BAU BAU!
Portable!
RYCZ!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!